Hey Thoughty2 here.
Let me tell you about a beautiful and very
real 19th century love story involving a spellbound
couple in love, a quaint little barn in the
English countryside and a bunch of body parts
sold at auction.
Well I never said it was a love story with
a happy ending.
In 1827 at 22 years of age William Corder
of Polstead, a sleepy English village in Suffolk
planned to elope to that most classic of elopement
locations, Ipswich, with Maria Marten, the
daughter of a local mole catcher.
They had planned to meet in the middle of
the night, at the local Red Barn, so named
because of its red roof.
And so Maria met Corder in the Red Barn that
night and she was never seen alive again.
Corder fled Polstead without talking to anyone.
I know, he didn’t even leave a note saying
I’ve just slaughtered my girlfriend in that
creepy looking barn, the cheek of it!
Maria’s remains were later discovered buried
in a grain storage bin at the Red Barn.
So I think the elopement went really well.
Corder evaded capture for some time but he
was eventually tracked down 90 miles away
in Brentford, London, where he had managed
to find a new lucky wife and was running a
ladies boarding house, the natural career
progression for any aspiring young psychopath.
After his capture the local newspapers reported
that he was found “…in parlour with 4
ladies at breakfast, in dressing gown & had
a watch before him by which he was 'minuting'
the boiling of some eggs.”
Let the man finish boiling his goddamn eggs
before slapping the cuffs on him, that’s
just downright rude.
But something about this murder and boiled
egg fanatic caught the public’s attention
and in a big way.
The media all over Britain were reporting
of William Corder’s story of elopement,
betrayal, murder, red barns and eggs, those
poor overcooked eggs.
The public went wild for it, they wrote songs
and performed plays of the infamous red barn
murder, as it has come to be known.
Well I guess we all needed something to occupy
our days with before Jeremy Kyle brought a
daily dose of inbreeding and social disfigurement
into our homes.
Now when I say the public went wild for this
unfortunate tale, I mean to say they behaved
like a pack of wild priests in a boarding
school.
The red barn itself was raided and completely
emptied by the public in search of souvenirs
from the crime scene.
Even the wooden panels from the floor and
walls were prised off and sold.
You can imagine it now “murder planks, get
your murder planks, only a shilling a piece,
the blood’s still warm folks”.
A novel was published about the case which
quickly became a best-seller.
Corder was hanged and immediately afterwards,
bits of the rope used to hang him were sold
to the public and most gruesome of all, his
body parts were chopped up and auctioned to
the highest bidders, not for medical purposes,
nope, just disturbing souvenirs.
Corder’s skin was even used to bind a book,
as can be seen here.
Some say afterwards the book grew hair.
All throughout the 18th and 19th centuries
plays were frequently performed detailing
the red barn murder.
Why?
Am I crazy for thinking that’s crazy?
Why did the public get so deeply enthralled
with this case?
Overnight William Corder had been raised to
celebrity or even rockstar status, yet Corder
was by all accounts a manipulative, lying,
cheating, abusive, meglomanic psychopath who
enjoyed chopping up women and hiding them
inside piles of grain.
His only redeeming feature was he cared deeply
about the doneness of a boiled egg.
In a perfect society should we not forget
about such an evil character, confining them
to the annals of history and not give the
case so much attention, thereby only glorifying
the horrible act that the killer performed?
Yet we do quite the opposite, we all do, we
are all obsessed with the sinister and macabre,
stop trying to hide it, you are too.
I’m just as guilty as the next man of cracking
open a beer and enjoying a Netflix documentary
about the next serial killer who may or may
not be guilty.
Why are novels, films and TV shows about killers
so much more popular than your average romcom?
Even in a world where romantic filmmakers
could actually write, I still believe this
would hold true.
Face it the sick general public absolutely
loves a good gruesome murder story and the
more kills the perpetrator has to their name
the more we lap it up like a sadistic, mentally
ill kitten.
And this has been the case for as long as
man with long beard and stubby nose hit man
with beady eyes over the head with big rock,
spilling red goo that man can’t drink all
over the cave floor.
Less than 150 years ago Jack the Ripper murdered
and disemboweled anywhere from five to eleven
prostitutes in Whitechapel, London.
Yet today he is much as a household name as
Jesus or Cillit Bang.
There are many Jack the Ripper fan clubs out
there, hundreds of books, plays, songs, TV
shows and films.
All because a crazy man down a back alley,
once sliced open some women to see what was
inside.
The ironic thing is Jack the Ripper knew how
sick the general public were and how famous
he would inevitably become, because he branded
himself.
In a letter that may have been written by
the man himself he administered himself the
moniker of “Jack the Ripper”.
I would have gone for Slicy Pete myself, but
I guess it’s a personal preference.
The stories of these professional psychopaths
are endless.
Such as Dr. Harold Shipman, nicknamed Dr.
Death, the doctor who murdered over 250 of
his own patients.
H.H. Holmes, the American serial killer who
designed and constructed a purpose built hotel
including hidden rooms and passageways in
the walls, for the sole purpose of torturing
and murdering his victims, of which there
were an estimated 200.
Luis Garavito, nicknamed The Beast, a Colombian
rapist and serial killer who sexually abused,
tortured and killed over 138 children.
And those are just the tip of a very large
and deeply evil iceberg.
The Yorkshire Ripper, Ian Brady and Myra Hindley,
Ted Bundy, Gary Ridgway, I could go on and
on all day.
In fact the United States has produced 2,743
serial killers, and the UK is hot on its heels
with 145 psycho murderers on its list.
But have you ever noticed how we glorify these
monsters by giving them cool sounding nicknames
Jack the Ripper, Dr. Death, The Beast, The
Grim Sleeper, Son of Sam, The Green River
Killer, The Lady Killer, BTK.
It’s like Quentin Tarantino and Wes Anderson
had a lovechild and it made a film about serial
killers.
You can just picture the beautifully pastel
coloured introductory title cards.
But don’t you think it's a bit strange how
we are quicker to give awesome sounding monikers
to mass murdering psychopaths than to our
favourite sports players.
It’s almost like the moment someone disposes
of a few people they automatically have a
god-given right to a cool nickname.
And the general public lap it up.
Swiss Psychiatrist Carl Jung believes it's
because we all need to feed our “shadow
self”.
Our shadow self is our dark side, that part
of you secretly wants to punch a nun in the
face, even though we know it's wrong.
We all have it and psychiatrists believe that
by watching serial killers on TV carrying
out heinous acts and learning how they performed
said acts, we are scratching that itch we
all have to explore our dark side, all from
the safe comfort of our couch.
Research shows we find indulging our dark
side, from afar, therapeutic.
Greek philosopher Aristotle was curious why
his fellow humans were obsessed with plays
about horrific things like murder.
Everyone loved a good tragedy.
Aristotle concluded that by experiencing what
he called “dark emotions” such as disgust,
fear and depravity we can cleanse ourselves
of such emotions.
It’s a kind of self healing, he called this
process catharsis.
So according to Aristotle, the next time you’re
lying in bed with your wife and that thought
pops into your head again “go on, just put
the pillow over her face, it will only take
a minute and I’ll be free”.
You should instead pop on a gory horror film
or true crime documentary and experience some
good old catharsis to cleanse that evil little
person from your mind.
And if that doesn’t work for you, them I’m
afraid you’re just going to have to start
planning where to hide the body.
Another reason why we find serial killers
absolutely fascinating is because of how perplexing,
difficult and alien the concept of committing
and getting away with multiple murders is
to us.
I’ve never tried it myself but I can imagine
it’s really difficult to murder someone
and not get caught, after all the majority
of murders are solved, approximately two thirds
of killers are eventually caught.
In today’s world of advanced forensics,
ballistics, criminal psychology, CCTV everywhere
and internet and phone tracking, no matter
how smart you think you are, only one tiny
mistake needs to be made before you’re found
out and cuffs have been slapped on your wrists
faster than you can say “the voices made
me do it”.
So naturally we find someone who can avoid
being caught for many years whilst committing
more than one murder, sometimes many many
murders, absolutely fascinating.
After all, that takes some skill.
On some level we find it impressive.
In the same way we find highly skilled acrobatic
skydivers doing twists and turns whilst plummeting
at terminal velocity towards a six-thousand
kilometre rock quite impressive.
We feel exhilarated when watching skydivers
because it’s a terrifying experience that
most of us would never dream of doing, yet
we all secretly want to know how it would
feel, so we can live that experience through
watching and learning about somebody else
doing it on our behalf.
In this regard, our fascination with serial
killers is no different.
Maybe this psychology also explains why so
many people watch horrendously trashy TV shows,
like Keeping up With The Kardashians and Honey
Boo Boo, just so we can experience through
others what it would feel like to be that
stupid.
There’s another deep-rooted evolutionary,
psychological reason for our love of serial
killers.
Uncertainty.
Humans hate the unknown, we always have, the
same fear of the unknown can be seen in other
intelligent creatures.
It’s why apes at the zoo always seem so
curious of new objects, they’re only interested
because they’re trying to discover if this
new object will hurt them or not.
And so too are humans afraid of what may be
around the corner, what is beyond the forest
or across the ocean.
During our 200,000 year span as modern homo
sapiens we have found a way to deal with our
fear of the unknown, we dominate it.
We can’t predict what a wild animal will
do when we meet it, it’s actions are unknown,
so we invented weapons to kill them.
We were afraid of what dangers may lie across
the ocean, so we invented boats and we took
our weapons and we dominated the oceans and
everything beyond them.
Simply because on a deeply psychological level
it terrified us, not knowing what may be out
there.
It has been suggested by many a psychologist
that serial killers kill for the exact same
reason.
Because they are afraid, so they feel the
need to dominate their environment.
Many have trouble speaking to and becoming
romantically entangled with women, so they
instead choose to dominate them through rape
and murder, it’s no coincidence that an
overwhelming amount of serial killers throughout
history have chosen prostitutes as their targets.
Some may have been beaten and abused as a
child so they fear what other humans may do
to them, thus they decide to dominate them.
Serial killers often practice this domination
on animals before humans, just as the human
race first practiced dominating cattle and
sheep, before using the exact same techniques
to enslave humans during times of war and
famine.
As observers we find people dominating others
absolutely fascinating, because it teaches
us how to conquer the unknown, we learn what
we might do if we were put into the same situation
of either the killer or the victim.
It’s the same macabre reason why horrific
car crash videos are so popular online, and
fail videos where people have horrendous,
bone-breaking accidents, even if sometimes
they did have it coming.
We aren’t all psychopaths, and although
it makes us feel guilty watching these videos,
all we are doing is feeding a primal urge
to dominate the unknown, deep down, we just
want to answer the question, what if?
What would happen if I was in that situation.
And by studying serial killers and enjoying
true crime documentaries, we find out what
happens if we were to go on a satanic killing
spree, and hopefully watching the story of
others unfold before us can dissuade us from
following a similar path, because others are
conquering the unknown for us, whilst we stuff
our faces with popcorn.
So thank you serial killers, you are providing
a vital service for all of humanity.
No wait, I can’t say that, I can’t actually
thank them, there are victims after all.
Okay how about, serial killers, you are very,
very naughty, but from your naughtiness may
we all learn to be better people, that’s
better, I think.
Thanks for watching.